I'm all for decreasing matchings
obviously I was kind of controversial
I'm
harder to get guns but if you pass it
get whatever
you want to solve the problem yeah it's
never been people finding random guns
all over the house some people are gonna
be pissed I want my son Bill to get a
gun
people are getting guns guns from the
black market they're getting scratched
out serial numbers you know bad guns
anyways they're not solving the problem
you can change the law but criminals
break the law they're like what are you
talking about what now they're breaking
all of the laws the law is already you
can't kill anybody yeah exactly yeah
right